hello this is Matthew from simply lab
and today we can continue our education
and DevOps and we're going to focus
specifically on puppet so in this
session what we can do is we're going to
cover what and why you would use puppets
what are the different elements and
components of puppet and how does it
actually work and then we'll look into
the companies that are adopting puppet
and what are the advantages that they
have now received by having puppet
within their organization and finally
we'll wrap things up by reviewing how
you can't you write a manifest in puppet
so let's get started
so why puppet so here is a scenario that
as an administrator you may already be
familiar with you as an administrator
have multiple servers that you have to
work with and manage so what happens
when the server goes down it's not a
problem you can jump onto that server
and you can fix it but what if the
scenario changes and you have multiple
servers going down so here is where
puppet shows its strapped with puppets
all you have to do is write a simple
script that can be written with Ruby and
write out and deploy to the servers your
settings for each of those servers the
code gets pushed out down to the servers
that are having problems and then you
can choose to either roll back to those
servers to their previous working States
or set them to a new state and do all of
this in a matter of seconds and it
doesn't matter how large your server
environment is you can reach to all of
these servers your environment is secure
you're able to deploy your software and
you're able to do this all through
infrastructure as code which is the
advanced DevOps model for building out
solutions so stick deeper into what
puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment
and you can have a guarantee that the
environment you want is written and
deployed accurately so let's go through
those components of puppet so here we
have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that will be running within your
network so we look at the top part of
the screen we have here our puppet
master store which has and contains our
main configuration files and those are
comprised of manifests that are actual
codes for configuring their clients we
have templates that combine our codes
together to render a final document and
you have files that will be deployed as
content that could be potentially
downloaded by the clients wrapping this
all together is a module of manifested
templates and files you would apply a
certificate authority to sign the actual
document so that the clients actually
know that they're receiving the
appropriate and authorized modules
outside of the master server where you'd
create your manifest templates and files
you would have public client is a piece
of software that is used to configure a
specific machine there are two parts to
the ground one is the agent that
constantly interacts with the master
server to ensure that the certificates
are being updated appropriately and then
you have the fact of it the current
state of the client that is used and
communicated back to through the agent
so let's step through the workings of
puppet so the puppet environment is a
master slave architecture the clients
themselves are distributed across your
network and they are constantly
communicating back to a master server
environment where you have your puppet
modules the client agent sends a
certificate with the ID of that server
back to the master and then the master
will then sign that certificate and send
it back to the client and this
authentication allows for a secure and
verifiable communication between client
and master the factor then collects the
state of the client and sends that to
the master based on the facts sent back
the master then compiles manifests into
the catalogs and those catalogs are sent
to the clients and an agent on the
client will then initiate the catalog a
report is generated by the client that
describes any changes that have been
made and sends that back to the master
with the goal here of ensuring that the
master has full understanding of the
hardware running software in your
network this process is repeated at
regular intervals ensuring all client
systems are up to date so let's have a
look at companies that are using puppet
today there are a number of companies
that have adopted puppet as a way to
manage their infrastructure so companies
that are using puppet today include
Spotify Google AT&T so why are these
companies choosing to use puppet as
their main configuration management tool
the answer can be seen if we look at a
specific company staples so staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the IT organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppet
enabled them to open up time to allow to
expand with other and new projects and
assignments a real tangible benefit to a
company so let's look at how you write a
manifest in puppet so so manifests are
designed for writing out in code how you
configure a specific node in your server
environment the manifests are compiled
into catalogs which are then executed on
the client each of the manifests are
written in the language of Ruby with F
dot PP extension now we step through the
five key steps for writing a manifest
they are one create your manifest and
that is written by the system
administrator to compile your manifest
there's compiled into a catalog three
deploy the catalog is then deployed onto
the clients four execute the catalogs
are run on the client by the agent and
then five and clients are configured to
a specific than desired state if we
actually look into how manifest is
written it
with a very common syntax of you done
any work with Ruby or really
configuration of systems in the past
this may look very familiar to you so we
spread out them the work that we have
here you start off with a package file
or service as your resource type and
then you give it a name and then you
look at the features that need to be
said such as IP address then you're
actually looking to have a command
written such as present or start the
manifests can contain multiple resource
types if we continue to write a node
manifest and puppet the default keyword
applies a manifest to all clients so an
example would be to create a file path
that creates a folder called sample in a
main folder called etc the specified
content is written into a file that is
then posted into that folder and then
we're going to say we want to be able to
trigger an Apache service and then
ensure that that Pachi service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an Apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you have exactly the same results on
those machines
so why puppet puppet is a tool to help
manage your infrastructure for your
hardware and the software installed on
those servers puppet is a tool that
makes it very easy through code to
implement consistent experiences across
your network the components of puppet
are really broken into two distinct
areas where you have a server where you
would write the manifests templates and
files and that server is a master server
and then you would have a client
installed on all the individual servers
within your network so you can then push
out instructions to those networks the
number of companies that are using
puppet is significant
they include companies such as Spotify
AT&T staples and Google and finally the
process for actually writing a manifest
is fairly easy you'll be able to pick
this up really quickly and this is truly
gonna help you better manage your
infrastructure through using code and
infrastructure as a code principles
thank you for joining us watching this
video if you
this hit subscribe below or ask us any
questions and in the comments below
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here